the protagonist of the movie is Jennifer
Hills a novelist from New York City
being an independent woman she is on her
way to a small village in Connecticut
where she has rented a cabin Jennifer
believes that the Serenity and calm
environment of the place will help her
overcome her writer's block reminds me
of Alan Wake great game pick it up after
a while she pulls over at a shop where
she is greeted by a shady looking guy
named Earl he appears to be the owner of
the cabin she has rented Earl hands her
the keys and gives her directions to the
place however Jennifer doesn't pay much
attention to this and simply leaves
after thanking him along the way she is
mesmerized by the beauty of the
countryside but she also gets confused
as all the roads seem to be the same so
she stops by a gas station to ask for
directions three men are working there
and all of them appear to be fraking
perverts from the moment Jennifer walks
in they begin staring at her in a creepy
way one of them named Johnny even
attempts to hit on her but Jennifer
retaliates causing him to stumble on a
bucket of oil this makes his friends
Andy and Stanley burst out in laughter
Jennifer also drives off and Johnny is
clearly embarrassed by the incident
nothing more dangerous than an
embarrassed idiot pervert in the next
scene Jennifer finally arrives at the
cabin which is near a beautiful Lake she
then unpacks her belongings and makes
herself comfortable at night she wastes
no time and starts working on her new
novel by the looks of how she is writing
it appears that the isolated setting is
helping her concentrate the next morning
as Jennifer is relaxing by the lake she
hears some strange no noises but she
chooses to ignore them believing that it
must be some animal however in the
evening the noise continues to persist
this annoys Jennifer as it is
interfering with her work so she decides
to investigate the source of the noise
after a while she comes across a nearby
shed and the noise seems to be coming
from inside it however when Jennifer
enters she finds nothing other than some
tools bottles of poison and other
Machinery following this she returns to
her cabin and proceeds to begin her work
but as she lifts her laptop she
accidentally spills her drink now that
Jennifer's clothes are dirty she takes
them off and washes them in the kitchen
sink surprisingly as she is doing so an
unknown person is seen recording her
don't worry it's just me your Airbnb
host perfectly legal I swear the next
morning Jennifer jogs through the woods
to keep herself fit along the way she
stumbles upon an abandoned house and
decides to check it out however when she
finds it to be creepy she quickly runs
away after a while she returns home and
decides to take a shower but the Taps of
appear to be clogged so she contacts the
plumber for assistance in the next scene
a guy named Matthew arrives to fix the
problem he appears to be suffering from
a mental disorder which makes it
difficult for him to speak nonetheless
he gets the job done and the water
starts flowing once again this makes
Jennifer so happy that she approaches
Matthew and gives him a sudden kiss the
ladder was not expecting this at all so
he runs away without even taking his
payment I'm sure he feels plenty
reimbursed the scene then cuts to the
three gas station douchebags who are
hanging out by the lake Stanley is
recording their interactions on his
video camera as he has a passion for
this just then a panicked Matthew comes
running towards them and explains how
Jennifer kissed him earlier Johnny
thinks he's bluffing but Stanley says it
might be true he then shows them the
secret footage of Jennifer he took the
other night since she was barely dressed
the group believes that she wants to
have some fun so they make an evil plan
to confront her later that evening
Jennifer is awakened by some strange
noises scared she decides to check it
and discovers 's a dead bird outside
when she returns to her room she finds
her laptop open and the wallpaper is of
the three guys from the gas station I'm
surprised they were smart enough to pull
that off this makes her realize that her
house has already been infiltrated as
Jennifer desperately screams for help
Johnny Andy and Stanley surround her
from different directions then Matthew
is also dragged into the room he doesn't
want to be here but because of pure
pressure he relents the group then uh
I'm going to make an executive decision
here and skip this part I I don't
understand movies that glamorize this
kind of stuff and I don't understand the
kind of audience that appreciates it
either I'm going to assume there's not a
whole lot of nuance here and uh we're
just going to move to the next part
Jennifer runs into the woods until she
comes across Earl and the local sheriff
Storch the ladder calms her down and
shows her his badge saying she is in
safe hands now he then sends Earl away
and takes her back to the cabin on the
pretense of confronting the bad guys
however as soon as they reach the place
Storch changes his attitude after
finding weed and some alcohol on the
table he suspects that she is lying
Jennifer desperately tries to claim that
she is the victim but he does not listen
instead he asks her to turn around so
that he can search her Jennifer
innocently complies and this is when we
skip forward again after all is said and
done Jennifer is barely conscious still
she gets up and walks deeper into the
woods hoping that she finds someone
however the evil men continue following
her they eventually Corner her on a
bridge and Storch is about to finish her
off but just then Jennifer jumps into
the river seeing seemingly committing
the unthinkable the group searches for
her but when they find no trace of her
they decide to erase all the evidence
they burn her stuff in the cabin and
Stanley is also ordered to destroy the
video footage I wonder if they deleted
the wallpaper though following this
Storch returns home to his family as if
nothing happened despite having a
daughter himself he did not hesitate to
destroy another girl's life the next day
he drives to Earl's shop and returns him
the cabin's key lying that Jennifer left
without any notice the movie then cuts
to several weeks later and the evil gang
seems to have put the incident behind
them they are living normal lives
drinking beer and having fun the only
one who appears to be affected is
Matthew as he spends most of his time
alone regretting his actions one day as
Johnny is chilling outside his house
Stanley comes running to him with some
bad news he reveals that someone has
stolen his camera and it had the
controversial footage which he didn't
destroy earlier this sends Johnny into a
fit of rage and he immediately attacks
his friend for putting their lives at
risk that night as Johnny is alone at
home a noise startles him when he goes
outside to check he finds a dead bird
thinking it's some kind of prank he
kicks the bird away and goes to sleep
however the noise persists prompting him
to check again to Johnny's shock the
dead bird is somehow resurfaced it's
almost as if someone is playing with him
Johnny says stop bringing me Birds you
stupid cat and then angrily goes inside
and grabs his gun but when he comes out
he finds Jennifer's slipper on his porch
this scares him so he furiously looks
around the area but finds no one
elsewhere as Storch returns home from
work his wife hands him a package saying
an unknown person delivered it the
sheriff believes that he's received an
early Christmas gift like the idiot he
is but to his horror it's actually one
of Stanley's illicit tapes Furious he
confronts the group and demands an
explanation he believes that Stanley is
doing this on purpose to destroy his
family however Johnny defends his friend
and brings out the slipper he says that
someone else is trying to mess with them
realizing that they are in grave danger
Storch decides to eliminate all the
loose endt the first victim is Earl as
he had seen Storch escorting Jennifer
into the cabin on that fateful night
then the sheriff decides to finish off
Matthew as he was never on board with
their plan the scene then cuts to
Matthew who is outside the cabin
reflecting on his gruesome past he still
has not been able to recover from that
incident just then he hears A peculiar
voice so he rushes inside the cabin as
he searches every room he accidentally
loses his footing and falls down the
stairs when he regains Consciousness he
is shocked to the Core by what he sees
Jennifer sits on the couch her eyes full
of anger Matthew approaches her and
profusely apologizes for his actions at
first Jennifer pretends to comfort him
but at an opportune moment she ties a
noose around his neck and seemingly
chokes him to death the next day as
Stanley and Andy are looking for Matthew
they come across the same abandoned
house from earlier Andy goes inside to
check it while Stanley remains outside
just then the ladder comes face to face
with Jennifer who has an evil grin on
her face he tries to Lunge at her but
gets caught in a bear trap that she had
placed there hearing his screams Andy
rushes out of the house but he is
swiftly knocked out by Jennifer Stanley
also receives the same fate when she
swings a baseball bat right across his
head how's that for getting to Third
Base douche in the next scene he wakes
up to find himself tied to a tree
Jennifer records the entire ordeal in
his camera just like he did with her
then she Begins the torture process At
first she shoves a rodent into his mouth
making him puke then she pieres oh Jesus
H uh let's just say he ultimately bleeds
to death after this we are shown the
condition of Andy who is tied above a
bathtub which is filled with boiling
water he is supported by a few planks of
wood Jennifer removes one of them so now
he has no choice but to support his
entire weight himself after a few
seconds his body eventually gives in and
he dies a horrible death in the boiling
water how's that for a hot night dick
balls the next day Jennifer goes to the
gas station wearing a seductive dress as
expected Johnny Falls for it and when he
approaches her she knocks him out with a
strike to the Head she then takes him to
the same abandoned house and ties him up
in a naked State following this she
begins torturing what is this what what
what what what what the what
what she pulls at his teeth one by one
while reminding him of the gruesome acts
he performed on her she also shoves her
gun down his throat just like he did to
her however instead of being apologetic
Johnny laughs maniacally it's almost as
if he has learned nothing from his
mistakes seeing this an enraged Jennifer
grabs a pair of scissors and oh oh
Johnny dies the next day as Storch is
driving he receives a call from his wife
she mentions that their daughter's
teacher is here and she wants to speak
with him when Storch learns that she is
none other than Jennifer he is taken AB
back he turns his car around and rushes
home fearing for his family's safety but
by the time he arrives he learns that
the teacher has already taken their
daughter to the park terrified he rushes
to the location and starts looking
around but out of nowhere Jennifer
ambushes him from behind and knocks him
out when Storch wakes up he finds a
rifle shoved inside his back Jennifer
pushes it in even further causing him to
scream in pain she then walks across the
room and uncovers a man who turns out to
be Matthew the guy is still alive but he
is unconscious Jennifer ties a string
around his hand and the other end is
attached to the rifle's trigger she
explains that if Matthew moves by even a
bit both of them will be killed she then
walks out of the room leaving the men at
the mercy of Their Own fate soon Matthew
awakens and when he finds himself in
this Shady room he immediately panics
this results in both of them being
killed on the spot the movie ends as
Jennifer faintly smiles she has finally
completed her revenge subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching